hey guys dr. Berg here in this video I
want to discuss probably one of the most
important body systems that you have
it's the digestive system ok so you have
33 feet of intestines and that's a like
you can mention a water hose in your
backyard it's a very long hose and it's
all wrapped around and there's a lot of
things that happen from start to finish
so let's just time to take from the top
you've got the stomach here which
normally what's interesting about the
stomach is that people don't realize how
acid the stomach should be if you
understand pH neutral is 7 and it goes
down to be more acid and higher to be
more alkaline for every number let's say
we go from 7 to 6 going down that's 10
times more acid so it it compounds so
you can imagine a pH of 1 to 3 that is
super super acidic okay that's what the
stomach should be normally and the
stomach actually helps you release the
stomach releases the acid triggers
enzymes that then help you break down
protein so they have very powerful proto
lytic enzymes so if there's a problem
with the valve on the top of the stomach
then that enzyme gets up into the
esophagus they can literally digest your
tissues up into your throat so it's that
powerful it helps you absorb minerals so
if you don't have the right acid in your
stomach you can't absorb like iron you
become anemic like even b12 will not be
absorbing either and that's another type
of anemia it also kills microbes because
microbes have a hard time living in that
acid and either even h pylori which is a
very nasty bacteria that causes ulcers
and other issues if your stomach is very
acidic that thing will stay in a mission
or not invade your tissues but if the
stomach is not asked enough it will not
release these to other organs called the
pancreas and the gallbladder so what
controls a pancreas in and the
gallbladder is really the pH of the
stomach pH of that stomach also controls
the valve of the top of the stomach so
without that stomach being acidic you
you can get GERD acid reflux and then
people take any acids which is the exact
opposite but what happens if you
you can't release the pancreas now we
don't we don't get the release of
enzymes so the pancreas has all these
different enzymes for carbohydrates
proteins fats collagen you name it and
it's constantly released depending on
which you eat so signals from your mouth
are telling the pancreas what to release
and what to create when you start eating
so so we have this enzyme breakdown and
then we have the gallbladder release
bile bile helps you break down fats
break down fat so you can absorb fat
side with vitamins vitamin A D and K and
then also help you it helps you detoxify
certain chemicals in the liver so
without the gallbladder we can't get
that full detox let these two work
together and then the bile is alkalyn so
it helps to neutralize this incredibly
strong acid coming into the small
intestine so if we didn't have the bile
we couldn't neutralize that and you
would get an ulcer in your small
intestine and then we have the pancreas
that also makes this other alkaline
fluid called bicarbonate that helps
neutralize the acid at this point too so
we go from a strong acid to a very
alkaline fluid inside the small
intestine so the small intestine is
alkaline okay and it's so funny when
people say well you need to be alkaline
well what part of the body you're
talking about because your stomach
better not the alkaline definitely the
small intestine should be alkaline but
the large intestine should be acidic so
you have different PHS so now in the
small intestine
this is where 90% of the digestion
occurs and you have helped though you
have microbes you have a lot of microbes
in fact in your body you have a thousand
trillion bacteria or microbes in your
body outside and inside that's a
thousand trillion that's a lot you only
have a hundred trillion cells so these
bacteria or these microbes have are ten
times more than your own self so if you
take a body it's mostly microbes so but
they're very small so you don't there's
like probably about three or four maybe
five pounds of microbes
per body weight but the microbes
basically help you break down your food
and help so you can absorb the food
there's thousands tens of thousands of
different strains of microbes in your
gut you have good bacteria and then you
have bad bacteria they're called
pathogenic now antibiotics destroy both
good and bad bacteria what's happening
now is the bad bacteria is adapting to
the antibiotics and they're becoming
more resistant so now the antibiotics
don't work but the good news is this
that the good bacteria also adapts to
the antibiotics if it didn't you'd be
probably be dead by now so your microbes
are very intelligent and they have
developed new strategies of surviving so
if you take a let's say someone comes in
your house and they try to steal
something and then you take a bat and
you whack them right well the next time
they come in their house they're they
wear a helmet so these microbes
basically have different ways of
adapting to survive one of the
interesting strategies some of these
microbes pulled off is they basically
can mimic and adapt to your vitamin D
receptors they mimic the vitamin D
receptor so when your vitamin D goes
into the wrong receptor it doesn't work
anymore so it's just as fascinated
because you need vitamin D for the
immune system so there's all these
different types of strategies that use
one type of micro adapted without a cell
wall so they can move into the joints
and then they can travel and they can do
this and they can hide so your immune
system can't detect them very
intelligent sneaky little guys but thank
goodness that our good bacteria also
adapt so we have 90% of the nutrient
nutrition absorption occurs at this
level with other another thing that's
interesting about this is that you have
something called the enteric nervous
system so you have the sympathetic which
is a flight-or-fight
that's like the stress nervous system
and then we have the parasympathetic
which is part of the rest and digest
which controls a lot of this - that's
that's kind of like the opposite of the
stress nervous system but then you have
the enteric which controls like all this
intestines and the peristalsis the
pumping action of the whole thing and if
years someone cut your spinal column for
example you could this will still work
because it's an independent nervous
system it can work on its own that's
what I call the second brain but the
challenge is that a lot of the
information that happens down here is
transmitted up to the brain so
whatever's going on your digestion can
affect your mood you could it could have
create depression anxiety and a lot of
tension in your neck and even a lot of
headaches so it's interesting how the
digestion can affect your mood and also
your mood could affect your digestion
both ways because it's a second brain
the bacteria also makes a lot of B
vitamins so what happens when I see
people with vitamin B deficiencies it's
not because they're not consuming them
is because they don't have the microbes
or they they don't have the good
digestive system to absorb those vitamin
B over those B vitamins or they they
make them but they can't get absorbed
because the surface lining of the
intestines is damaged so I'll get to
that in a little bit but what these
microbes eat or consume is fiber
preferably when we want to feed them a
vegetable fiber and they turn it into
something called butyrate which is a
type of acid that then will feed the
colon cells so it's it's interesting
these microbes actually exchange with us
we help them they we provide a house and
they give us food as well so that's what
happens in the small intestine and the
large intestine is mainly responsible
for reabsorption of water and minerals
but this is where you have the highest
concentration of microbes so without the
microbes here you'll get diarrhea okay
the little little roots that occur in a
small intestine are called little villi
they're upside down roots and that's
where it absorbs and you have like a
million bacteria per millimeter like a
real small surface area there's a so
many compacted microbes in there
that are supposed to help you absorb and
write when it gets absorbed it goes
right into the lymphatic system 80% of
your lymphatic system is surrounding
your intestines so 85% of your immune
system is really connected to your gut
and it's there and it's kind of like
immigration to give these microbes a
stamp of approval or not approval to not
let them through so there's a barrier
there that resists microbes that are
unfriendly so when you destroy these
little so-called villi or little roots
you get this small surface area where
you now you can't you lose your
immigration so now my unfriendly
microbes can innervate and start to go
into the lymphatic system and create
health for the immune system that's
where you get autoimmune diseases that's
where the immune system you know starts
giving the wrong information and
attacking it's not creating antibodies
for your own tissue
it's like self attack so you have a lot
of inflammatory conditions that
originated from this lining that you
lose the structure okay so there's a
couple things that you can do number one
you have to build up the flora and I
think the best way is to take something
called effective microbes I'll put a
link down there I'm not affiliated I
don't get any Commission's or anything
but I'll put a link down there of
effective microbes and you can check it
out but effective microbes is the
symbiotic a group of microbes that
basically all live on each other so they
kind of work together and you want to
take very very very small amounts
starting out because if you have too
many unfriendly strains you can create a
war so you want to take them right
before you go to bed and then they'll
grow in your system over a period of
time so effective microbes are very
important and then to retrain your
immune system your t-cells and start to
put back that immune system I recommend
something called colostrum and again
I'll put a link down there below I'm not
affiliated with any companies but this
is a really good thing too
your immune system and it's really
really good for rheumatoid arthritis
it's good for inflammation it's good for
autoimmune it's good for allergies it's
really good for sinus mucus it's good
for any type of inflammatory condition
but I will say when you take this start
off taking very small amounts maybe 1/4
of a teaspoon before bed why because if
you don't have a good immune system
you're going to stir up a hornet's nest
and you're gonna get more mucus that
it's gonna kick in there so you always
want to start very small over a gradual
period of time to start introducing
these 2 things so and I also recommend
al glutamine - those three are really
good to start building up the intestinal
wall and then over time you'll start
getting your immune system back ok so I
hope that kind of gave you a summary of
how this digestive system works and put
your comments below